Nikhil: From calorie
count to portion sizes,
we wanted to find out all the differences
between Dunkin' Donuts
in India and in the US.
This is "Food Wars."
Here in the US, you can get your doughnuts
in one; six, or a half dozen;
or 12, aka a dozen.
Don't put that in there.
Here in India, you can get your doughnuts
in packs of one, three, or six.
One US sticky glazed doughnut.
Nikhil: Indian glazed doughnut.
Joe: It weighs ...
Nikhil: 49 grams.
Joe: 59 grams.
In the US, we have four
sizes of hot coffee.
The small, the medium, the large,
which, unfortunately, they forgot.
Dunkin'!
And the extra large.
Here in India, our filter coffee
comes in one size, this one.
If you're wondering what filter coffee is,
it's one of the most popular
drinks here in India.
It's made by taking a decoction of coffee,
mixing it with sweetened milk,
and typically when they're preparing it,
they pour it from a huge
height to create this froth.
It's super delicious,
and it's very strong.
It'll wake you right up in the morning.
As for our other drinks,
they come in two sizes.
Either medium or large.
This is an Americano.
Let's weigh it to see how much we got.
I might have to go to
the bathroom after this.
10.14 fluid ounces.
If that's not enough for you,
Dunkin's in the US also has a Box 'O Joe,
which contains 100 ounces of hot coffee.
And ...
[groaning]
Guzh!
Oh, yeah.
This should be the extra large.
In the US, we "only" have
three iced-coffee sizes.
The small, the medium, and the large.
No extra large, but they did remember
the large iced coffee,
so, thanks, Dunkin'.
So, the Dunkin' India website says
that they serve an iced Americano.
But we asked three
outlets here in Bengaluru,
and they said no iced Americano.
We even asked them,
"Hey, can you put some
ice in our Americano?"
They said no.
So if you really must have an Americano
that's iced from Dunkin',
you have to take your
own ice and go there.
So, what's the large?
Is this supposed to be 32?
I mean, I think it's --
Yeah, cup says 32, it's supposed to be 32.
Yuelei, zoom in on that
and shame this business!
32?
This is everything that
you'll find on the menu
at Dunkin' Donuts India that
you will not find in the US.
Here is everything you can
get in a US Dunkin' Donuts
you can't get in India.
Let's start off with this
one. It is called Choco Villa.
And I think it's called that
because there's a little
triangle of chocolate,
which looks like those houses
we used to draw as kids.
Oh, my God.
Yum!
It's filled with my favorite
doughnut filling ever,
which is Bavarian cream.
Choco almond.
Hm, it's OK.
It's filled with the Bavarian cream again.
With the cream, unreal.
On to the next one. This
is called a Chocoholic.
It's got a piece of KitKat
sticking through it.
I want to see if it's one KitKat
bar or if they've taken two
and they've sandwiched them together.
Let's pull from this end.
Yeah, I was right.
If you're a chocoholic,
this is the one for you.
The inside has also got
chocolaty filling in there.
Chocolate is starting to
hit me real hard right now.
This stuff is so sweet.
This is called Rainbow Crunch.
Oh.
There's strawberry frosting on top.
So this has a strawberry taste.
It's OK. It's a doughnut.
Next up, we have Cookie Delight.
It's called Cookie Delight
'cause they've taken cookie
powder and smacked it on top.
This one's called Crispy Crunch.
For people who have trypophobia,
this one is probably not for you.
Oh, my God, this ain't it.
The crispy stuff on top
is just not working.
Again, however, they do have
the Bavarian cream inside --
I feel like there's a hurricane
inside my body right now.
Next up, we have a
doughnut called the Gemmy.
My fellow Indians will recognize
that there are gems on top.
This is one of the most nostalgic
chocolates here in India,
and I've eaten them since I was a kid.
Super yum.
You'd think a kid would like them,
but I can't even imagine
a kid version of myself
liking something that's so overdosed
with sweetness and chocolate.
Is it Gemmy? Yes.
Too Gemmy? Also yes.
I'd avoid.
So, I thought this was all
the exclusive signatures,
but I've been told that
there are two more.
And let's start off with this
one. It's called Choco Pop.
It's got chocolate on
top, chocolate sprinkles,
chocolate wavy line things,
and it's filled with chocolate.
It's very sweet.
Ah.
Whew!
All right.
And on to our last doughnut.
This one is called the Choco Berry Bomb.
That's actually quite nice.
It has definitely cut the
sweetness that I've experienced.
There's, like, some berry jam inside,
which is kind of tart and nice.
The top is milk chocolate with
shavings of white chocolate.
Whew!
Yeah, it's a good doughnut.
I wouldn't order it. It's too much.
All of this, I would
not order any of these.
They're too much.
Exclusive doughnuts you can get in the US
you can't get in India.
Now, we're filming this
the first week of October.
Of course, the No. 1 flavor
you get this month is pumpkin.
Mm, so pumpkiny.
Yeah, this tastes just like pumpkin pie.
Also, you can get yourself
a glazed blueberry doughnut.
See? Look at that.
Glaze on top, blueberry
dough on the inside.
Also delicious. Love it.
Glazed chocolate. Figured
this was everywhere, right?
So good.
Ooh, Boston cream.
The Ben Affleck of doughnuts.
Looks like a regular doughnut,
doesn't it, everyone in India?
But
surprise, there's cream on the inside!
I know everyone likes doughnuts,
maybe I haven't had a doughnut in a while,
but crap, this is really good.
One of my favorites.
I f--- with these.
Double chocolate, maybe my favorite,
'cause they just did what they had to do.
Take a chocolate doughnut and
put that chocolate frosting
I like right on top of
it. A double threat.
Oh, these are so good.
I am in heaven!
A strawberry frosting with sprinkles?
You don't got this?
This is, like, the Homer
Simpson doughnut, right?
This is the one that you
always see him eating.
Oh, the vanilla cream.
Gotta say, don't think I've
ever had this one before.
Look at me.
It's like "Scarface" over
here. I'm just covered.
A little much.
Ugh! Ugh!
Oh, God.
Here's some powder right here.
Powdered doughnut.
India, you don't know what this is?
C'mon. It's, like, doughnut No. 1, right?
Also in the US you can get a
vanilla frosted with sprinkles,
and a bear claw, which they
unfortunately did not have
at the time of shooting this.
Anyway, ah.
Munchkins? You guys don't got Munchkins?
What?
We have a variety of Munchkin flavors,
but this one specifically
is the pumpkin Munchkin,
and,
mm!
Tastes just like pumpkin pie. Fantastic.
Hey, guys, we're now on to a
different category of doughnuts
called the all-time favorites.
I took a quick hospital visit,
and I'm completely fine now.
I'm sorry about the madness
from the previous set of doughnuts.
I'm fine now. I don't
know what came over me.
OK, so we'll start off with
this specimen over here.
It's called a Cookie Cartwheel.
Adorable name, and, yes,
it does look like a wheel.
I like how they put the white stripes.
Yeah.
It's sweet.
Next up on our list is a doughnut
that's not intimidating at all,
it's only called Death by Chocolate.
Will this kill me?
Probably not.
But will this give me some
diabetes if I eat too much?
Absolutely.
And for that reason,
it's a win in my book.
If you thought Death
by Chocolate was scary,
this is Alive by Chocolate.
In terms of visual
differences, I can already tell
this one has more of a
cookie crumble on top.
They're very similar, as expected.
I will say, this one, it feels more, like,
it lifts your spirits
and you feel more alive.
And this one will probably
put you to sleep, in a coma.
So death and alive, it makes sense.
[ears ringing]
Mm, whoa!
On to the next one. We
have something called
Very Very Strawberry.
Vanilla frosting on top,
it's got some pink streaks,
and it looks to be stuffed
with strawberry jam.
Which sounds amazing,
especially after all
this chocolate overdose.
It's sweet.
Oh, my God.
It's nice, though.
All right, it's time
for our final doughnut,
and this one is a bit of a boss battle.
So, this is a doughnut eclair.
It's called the Breakup Party Eclair.
I guess because if you
go through a breakup,
this is what you end up eating.
So, the first few bites were quite nice.
They weren't as sweet, and
they didn't feel as rich.
But I realized most of the
chocolate is kind of centered
towards the center of the eclair.
And so it's a lot more
decadent the closer you get.
Great for breakups, great as
a metaphor for what you feel
when you're going through a breakup,
and as a doughnut itself, pretty average.
Both hot and cold espresso
and coffee drinks in the US
have options for flavors
you can add as flavor shots,
which are unsweetened,
or flavor swirls, which
are sweet and creamy.
Now, flavors unique to
the US include shots of
vanilla, toasted almond, blueberry,
raspberry, and coconut.
And flavor swirls, you can get
French vanilla and pumpkin.
So, I went ahead and had each
one of those swirls and shots
added to one coffee,
right here in front of me.
We'll call it the Food Wars DrinkAroo.
I don't know what it is.
All the flavors in one drink.
The lady when I ordered
it was like, "Really?"
And I was like, "Really."
Oh, God, this is so bad.
Oh, ugh!
Just blegh. Whoa!
Oh, man.
[exhales sharply]
It's like, there's, like,
an electric charge to it
at the end I don't quite understand.
Mm.
Oh-ho-ho-ho-ho!
This is poison. Don't get it.
All right, it's time for drinks.
Let's start off with the cold options
that we have here at Dunkin' India.
The first one is a classic lemonade.
Let's go ahead and try it.
It looks very clear.
That was nice. Refreshing.
They have not made it too
sweet, and I kind of like it.
Next up, we have a virgin mojito.
I don't see why somebody
would go to Dunkin' Donuts,
get a doughnut, and then a
virgin mojito on the side.
Quick point to make: You can
get them in a small bottle,
or you can even get
them in larger options.
Next up, we have two flavors of iced tea.
We have lemon and peach.
I'm going to try the peach.
If I had to pick one of these,
this is the one I'd go for.
Exclusive hot drinks here in
the US, we have these three.
The first one is, like, a
specific coffee blend at Dunkin'
called Dunkin' Midnight.
Oh, wow, that has,
[stammers] that's strong.
Wow.
It's, like, really
strong. I kinda love it.
Moving on, you can get
yourself a chai latte.
India doesn't have chai
lattes? What's going on, guys?
That's really good.
And, of course, a matcha latte.
No, not matcha.
I hate matcha.
That's the green one, right?
Beverages that taste like lawn clippings.
Mm-mm.
Ugh. I hate it.
All right, it's now
time for our milk-based
cold beverages here in India.
We have a range of frappés,
some iced shaken coffees.
Let's start with the frappés.
Coffee, caramel, and hazelnut.
And they have a seasonal
flavor, which is Alphonso mango.
If you've not heard of the
Alphonso variety of mangoes,
it grows all over here in India,
and it is the king of mangoes.
You have to try it if you get a chance.
I'm going to start off with this one,
because I love mango-flavored anything.
It's not bad.
Next up, we have some shaken iced coffees
in three flavors, caramel,
classic, and hazelnut.
Also the classic flavored
shaken iced coffee,
it's not as sweet, and I want
to put this one on a pedestal.
Thank you.
OK, next up, they also sell a
iced mocha and an iced latte.
It's time for the chocolate milkshake,
and can I just say, looks decadent.
It's quite thick. It's kind of grainy.
Like, you can taste the
graininess of the chocolate,
which I like, but I don't know,
some people might not like that.
Some people might like really
smooth chocolate milkshakes.
OK, so if you're traveling to India
and you must eat at Dunkin',
I would recommend you have
the Alphonso mango
frappé if it's in season.
But I would also say, don't go to Dunkin',
go to any juice shop, you'll
find them all across India,
and they take fresh mangoes,
and they make you a mango milkshake
that will blow your mind.
They'll put actual pieces
of Alphonso pulp in there,
and you'll chew on it while
you drink your milkshake.
Godsends.
Joe: So, they made these
two hours ago. I'm sorry.
Assume they don't look like this.
Anyway, we have these
cold drinks in the US.
They're called refreshers.
They're actually pretty
good, surprisingly.
Starting down here, we have
the strawberry dragon fruit.
I am such a child. It's spelled
S-T-R-A-W-D-R-G-N-F-R-T,
and all I could think
of was "dragon fart."
Wow, that's actually pretty good.
Peach passion fruit.
[laughing] F-R-T.
I keep thinking "fart." I'm such a child.
[fart tooting]
Whoa! Blegh! What the hell?
I think all the syrup went to the bottom.
It's way stronger than it should be.
Yeah, 'cause up top it's really weak.
Somewhere between there's a
good sip, but I didn't find it.
Anyway, all right.
Peach passion fruit coconut.
Oh, well this is -- is
that cool? Does that work?
OK.
Ah, no.
Oh, gross. Yeah.
The coconut ones are bad.
Keeping it up on the cool drinks,
you can get yourself a frozen coffee,
a frozen matcha latte, a frozen chocolate,
and, of course, the Coolattas.
Wait, frozen hot chocolate?
Isn't that just chocolate milk?
Oh, man, that is strong.
That is a milkshake.
Yo.
It's not terrible. The
flavor is very strong.
This is apparently a blue raspberry.
Think they have other flavors, but.
Once upon a time, I
worked at a movie theater.
Yes, really.
But we figured out a way
to get into the syrup box,
'cause fountain drinks,
it's syrup and soda water
at the same time, and it mixes
right when you pour it in.
It was a really dark color,
and we dared each other to drink it.
I remember it was so powerful,
I thought I was gonna throw up.
And I never experienced anything
that powerful-flavored, until today.
Surprise, surprise.
Dunkin' Donuts also sells chai.
So, you have two flavors,
this is ginger chai,
and we have elaichi chai.
Elaichi is cardamom.
Ginger in Hindi is adrak.
And it's just such a beautiful
word to say, oh, my God!
Adrak chai!
Oof, they've gone heavy
on the ginger for sure.
As advertised, these do taste like
elaichi, which is cardamom, and ginger.
Yeah, they don't quite have the soul
of a chai that you get on the roadside,
but I really love how
Dunkin' has tried to do this.
Makes you feel a little bit more at home,
so thank you, Dunkin'.
Sandwiches, and wraps, and
bagels, and breakfast stuff.
Oh. My.
Get a good look, India.
We have a huge selection
of non-doughnut-y breakfast sandwiches,
variety stuff you can get.
Oh, man, I hit a wall, and I apologize.
And I'm back.
You can get yourself maple
sugar bacon breakfast sandwich.
We have these Wake-Up Wraps,
and Wake-Up Wraps are,
I don't know, really
phoned-in breakfast tacos.
I don't know how else to describe it.
It's a tortilla. They put
the stuff they already had
for the other sandwiches in there.
They fold it over.
I'll just grab one. You
can get yourself one,
and oh, man, this thing is like ...
[glass shattering]
Hey, everyone watching this video,
in the comments, let me know:
I show you this, and then when I open it,
are you more likely to
eat this or less likely?
Let me know in the comments.
Dunkin', nobody wants these.
You can get yourself a
tomato pesto grilled cheese.
Pesto's fine and all, but
when something has pesto on it
and you don't realize it,
doesn't this look like --
like, look at this green.
Does that look like,
would you go, "Oh, it's pesto,"
or would you be like, "Ugh,
I think that's moldy"?
Also got the grilled cheese.
Oh!
[gavel thuds]
Then you get yourself a
sourdough breakfast sandwich.
Yo, these things solidified.
Probably edible a few hours ago.
I'll take a bite of this.
Sausage, egg, and cheese.
Yeah, not bad.
Bacon, egg, and cheese.
Somewhere encased in this
melted cheese is bacon,
I assure you.
There's also a turkey sausage,
egg, and cheese somewhere.
Oh, you can also get bagels
at your Dunkin' Donuts.
Why? I don't know.
But you can get your bagels plain,
cinnamon raisin, multigrain,
sesame seed, and this one, everything.
And you can get yourself
some cream cheeses,
including garden veggie,
strawberry, and plain.
Also you can get an avocado spread,
which they did not include.
Dunkin'!
India, you're not gonna believe this.
Our Dunkin' Donuts, you
can get a side of, [laughs]
you can get a side of something
called snackin' bacon.
What's snackin' bacon, you ask?
It is a bag of bacon.
Bagel minis.
You can get plain and everything bagels.
Here's one right now.
I think these have cream
cheese inside of them.
Yeah.
I don't think I've ever
had one of these before.
That's not a bad idea.
Not bad, guys.
Also in the US, you can get
an order of hash browns.
Now, at Dunkin' Donuts,
apparently you can get these,
what do we call these?
Omelet bites?
You get bacon, egg, and cheese
or egg white and veggie.
C'mon. This is straight
taken from Starbucks, right?
We went to the Dunkin' India
website, and over there,
on the menu, they claim to sell burgers
and a few sides, like nachos.
However, we went to the outlets,
and the managers said
that they're phasing out
all savory food in Dunkin' nationally.
But he was kind enough to make us
one single non-veg burger,
just so that we get to taste
what it would've been like.
It has a whole chicken piece in there,
which is already kind of nice.
Some onions, what looks
like tandoori mayo,
and the bun. Looks pretty tasty.
Oh, my God.
That's actually really good.
I've done many episodes of "Food Wars,"
tasted many burgers from restaurants
that are literally burger joints,
and this literally rivals those burgers.
This is pretty good.
What's happening, Dunkin'?
OK, so, the fact is that
Dunkin' has actually
scaled down massively here in India.
In Bengal, where we're filming,
there used to be 20 Dunkin' Donut outlets.
Now there are only three.
So rumor has it that Dunkin' might be
phasing out of India in general,
and the decision is going to
be made in the coming weeks.
So maybe this video is
the last remaining legacy
of Dunkin' in India.
And this is probably the last
burger that is ever eaten.
Oh, dude, this might be the --
guys, this might be the
last burger ever consumed
from Dunkin' Donuts here in India.
OK, let's talk price.
This large Americano is rupees 139,
which is currently $1.71.
But keep in mind, at the
time that we're filming this,
the Indian rupee is at an all-time low,
so hopefully things will get better
and this won't cost so much.
That same drink in the US is $3.69,
or 293.44 rupees.
That's a 63.9% increase in price.
OK, so the biggest menu item
that we have here in India
is our box of six.
Now, you can get two categories.
You can get classic doughnuts,
which are a lot simpler,
and it'll cost you rupees 399.
Or you can get the favorites doughnuts,
which we have here, which
are a lot more extravagant
and will cost you rupees 499,
which amounts to USD 6.12 right now.
If you want 12 doughnuts, you
need to get two boxes of six,
which will cost you rupees 998.
For food, our biggest menu
item is a dozen doughnuts.
$18.73,
or 1,492.85 rupees.
Thank you.
Our biggest drink is
the Box O' Joe Avella.
It's the most expensive single menu item.
$27.48,
or 2,190.25 rupees.
Now, in India we have
something called a vada,
which is pretty much a doughnut,
but it's savory and it's fried.
And I want to say that
those cost around 20 rupees,
while this original glazed
that I've bitten into a few times
costs 85 rupees.
So, it's important to know
this price difference,
and people here will
definitely think about that
before buying something like this.
Nikhil, stop eating the props!
OK, so Dunkin' Donuts
India has not released
any of their nutritional
info out for the public.
And they've not gotten back to us
when we asked them for
information, as of now.
However, I can confirm that one doughnut
is probably less
nutritious than one salad.
Let's talk about Dunkin' US nutrition,
starting with the glazed doughnut.
In the US, it has 360 calories,
22 grams of fat,
10 grams of saturated fat,
420 milligrams of sodium --
420.
39 grams of carbs,
and 18 grams of sugar.
And let's compare that
doughnut to this one,
the Boston cream.
In the USA, a Boston
cream is 270 calories,
11 grams of fat,
320 milligrams of sodium,
39 grams of carbs,
and 18 grams of sugar.
Dunkin' Donuts large iced
Dunkin' dark-roast coffee
with cream and sugar, in the US,
is 260 calories,
12 grams of fat,
and 37 grams of carbs.
Now, assuming that the iced coffee
is the same in the US and India,
getting a large iced
coffee with cream and sugar
and both the glazed and
a Boston cream doughnut
is 890 calories.
That's 35.6% of your daily calorie intake.
Yo.
Again, Dunkin' Donuts has not released
any of their ingredients to the public.
However, there is one huge difference
between the US and Indian doughnuts,
and that is that the Indian
doughnuts are all eggless.
This is because a huge percentage
of Indians are vegetarian,
especially Hindus, and so
they even consider eating egg
as non-veg food, and so, yeah.
Most fast-food restaurants
have decided to not use egg
in any of their foods to
make it more accessible
to a larger part of India.
But the US does have it on its site,
so we'll share with you
the ingredients right now.
First up, the coffee.
Regardless of getting it hot or cold,
if you get it black, it's going
to be 100% arabica coffee.
Nice. Now,
if you want to add cream and sugar to it,
then you are adding milk, cream,
disodium phosphate as a stabilizer,
sodium citrate as a stabilizer, and sugar.
If you're going to be adding
flavor to your coffee drink,
one flavor you can get in both
India and the US is caramel.
And in the US, our caramel
flavor is made up of all this.
In the US, our standard glazed doughnut
is made up of all of these things.
You think that's a lot?
Here's everything in our
Boston cream doughnuts.
Yikes, that's a lot of words.
Hey, everyone, its Harry Kersh
from the "Food Wars" team.
I finally got to meet my cohost Joe Avella
for a cool new project we're
working on called "Food Tours."
Here's the trailer for it now.
Joe: Oh, yeah?
Harry: It's so good, man.
This thing is incredible!
Oh, my God!
Harry: Can I shock you, Joe?
I quite like this.
Oh, yeah!
Yo, what's up with that egg
over there? What is that?
Harry: That's the Gherkin.
Joe: [laughing] What is it really?
Harry: That's literally the Gherkin.
Joe: That's not the Gherkin.
People of the internet,
you cannot expect me to
pick this up with my hands.
Harry: Oh, ho, ho, man.
At this point, I think I
could race a small car.
Yeah.
Like, one of those small cars,
I could race one of those.
How many more doughnuts do we have?
'Cause I'm taking on a cheetah
at the end of this episode.